moi je suis très heureux d'être sur la
scène du tedx grand bassin je commence
par deux questions est-ce que parmi vous
dans la salle
quelqu'un a déjà appelé les secours il
ya pas beaucoup beaucoup ma deuxième
question est ce que ceux qui ont déjà
payé ses coûts ou blesser les gens
non non
faux lui
mon espoir était fils biologique de la
revue à la baisse
pourquoi parce que je le connais on dit
c'est la première fois je m'en a pris
mais nationale ma mère du sel
nous sommes réputés du maire dans le
sobre et élégant pour mardi
moi c'est parfait du percement des
parcelles soit vers ma merde et je
refuse parce que personne je ne parle
pas
non merci
je suis pas mal elle a perdu à
treichville
parce que là tu mets les confrères que
je voyais elle savait pas qu l'a8 et
n'hésitez pas à part entière les
personnes qui font des gars plus âgés
avec une approche qui sont contents mais
la voiture est bon je suis là et je suis
témoin
c'est lui qui a question qu'ils ont
27 mai par contre c'est série de modules
et les uns c'est violer des départs seul
parce que plus le cadre du projet vivent
ici c'est pas seulement ici là c'est pas
chez moi alors j'ai rencontré groupe de
rap a piqué les thématiques dont je
connais mon geste est beau ce créateur
n'est pas parce que 29 ans et j'ai dit
oui le foot soit et nous tentons de
tournage pour moi qui ravagent des
braves parce que tu en es et emilie les
jours
curieusement la caméra j'apprends la
caméra et environ après la crise
je suis en particulier le lit de la
sécurité de côte d'ivoire je crois aux
vertus de la part des officiels et des
réseaux sociaux
j'ai continué nos socios un pas qu'ils
voient
on verra
souvent je suis suivi par son pote
d'abord qu'on sécurité des excuses
les gens étaient un peu de temps pour
mettre en exergue la question alors que
tu peux vous aider les banques d'être
relié par là sont pas perdus alors dû
propose des touches de la police de se
servir des réseaux sociaux
une fois des sms les appels recevoir des
rides et mais c'est parce que ça pas de
sécurité donc est ce qu'on va voir
comment ça marche
gfr avec en fer de soutenir la chanson
qui lui même et à la souris ocz a été
supprimée en septembre 2015
commençons seulement tout le monde est
rentré nous avions dû nous qu'est ce que
c est
après l'histoire fait quoi d'être au
lycée pour certains de mouvements sur
éleveurs
du neuf ans j'ai vraiment symphorien
ville égaré avec à l'intérieur une photo
de la plateforme
la faute aux services compétents et
après sa publication il ya les qui
arrive et il fait un post coup dit mais
c'est pas possible ce truc là ça marche
parce que je viens à peine de publier et
la police est là donc ça marche et ça
fait un bout des gens commencent à venir
et aux épaules et sait on dépasse ce que
nous nous sommes dit dès le départ nous
nous sommes dit que nous allons
rapprocher la population de sa police
parce que c'était difficile de jeunes
d'un numéro de secours de 180 277 où
nous avons commencé à faire maintenant
d'humanitaire des enfants disparus qu'on
retrouvait je peux déjà vous expliquer
l'histoire de cette petite maeva qu'1 2
5e en a 9 ans elle sa passion c'est les
études et un matin on a une publication
de sa mère qui dit que ça fait quarante
huit heures qu'elle ne retrouve pas
maeva maeva n'est pas venu à la maison
on publie sa photo bien évidemment et
ont reçu un appel lancé un message de
des membres qui nous dit mais moi je
suis professeur dans un lycée et cette
petite l'âge et le bus ce matin 1 passe
mais ça va pas être possible puisque sa
maman la recherche commun et la classe
en par trois administrateurs
vont sur place on arrive à l'école de
magie va effectivement la petite en
classe en appel
maeva que s'ils se passe ta mère tu sais
ça fait deux jours pourquoi pourquoi
t'es pas la maison elle a dit à mon
franchement depuis la classe de cp1
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai su première et
maman maman a quitté la maison on est
allé on est dans une danse dans une
baraque et ya pas de l'électricité
j'arrive pas à étudier
du coup le tri baisse on vient de donner
les résultats du trimestre je suis
deuxième donc moi je suis pas contente
enfin marie va on envoie maeva on
appelle sa mère ont dit bon écoute et
madame est une bonne nouvelle on a
retrouvé ma vie va mais tenez vous bien
en place et comprend pas on va vers la
même mais est-ce plus que nous quel est
le problème
à 10 ans j'ai quitté le père du mari va
j'ai pas les moyens
tout ce que j'ai je suis allée près une
baraque que gpa 7000 francs y a pas
d'électricité est là dedans vraiment
c'est ce que je peux faire pour elle et
une torche si elle peut étudier en a
cassé depuis bas
connaissez-vous encore enfin de
publication et on demande de l'aide aux
gens de dieu merci la présidence de la
république de côte d'ivoire nous
appellent et prennent en charge maeva de
la 5e à la terminale dans un internat
and you man avec rooney ce merci
avec promesse si elle a le bac d'aller
continuer ses études en france donc il
va alors aujourd'hui je voudrais dire à
mes frères qui sont là mes petits frères
peut-être même des confrères il faut
toujours te dise soi même
qu'est ce que j'apporte à ma communauté
moi je suis mécanicien
je suis cordonnier je suis maçon
qu'est ce que j'apporte à ma communauté
c'est ça la vérité c'est ça tout le
monde présidents de la république
le puzzle la république c'est pas celui
qui au palais 7 nous tous dans ce
périmètre qui a le plus dans la
république quel apport pour la
communauté parce que nous avons fait la
police est pour aujourd'hui nous sommes
deux cent trente mille membres et nous
sommes entrain de granby
nous sommes dix administrateurs qui sont
là j'aimerais vraiment que voulait
remercier de la france et en plus nous
sommes bénévoles nous recevons pas euros
un centime de qui que ce soit nous avons
nous donnons les alertes avec notre
téléphone avec
notre paix didata jeunes musulmans que
le partenaire est là et qu'à partir de
ce soir pour la vie tous les to les dix
animateurs auront un mobile et puis donc
c'est ça l'histoire de connaissez pour
les soirs de policiers coup c'est ça
c'est l'antre est aujourd'hui cette
communauté presque tout le monde est là
madonna question kinetic ont appelé les
secours
voilà tout le monde alors supposé se
courront centre est ce qu'ils sont en
france ceux qui sont aux etats unis tout
le monde on a montré on a demandé aux
gens d'en montrer aux gens qu'on peut
s'entraider
on peut s'aider je me rappelle de
l'histoire de cette dame qui a sa maison
en feu à engrais pour ceux qui
connaissent pas abidjan engrais
c'est un quartier de la commune de
cocody alors il est 1h du mat fn
publication au secours ma maison en feu
bon et bien évidemment nous sommes des
bénévoles donc par monde ont aussi il
est 1h bref on se réveille le matin es4
es5 un endroit un autre test de la dame
je vous remercie
je remercie tout le monde les pompiers
sont venus à temps vraiment ou a bien
suivi et on a un commentaire d'une dame
qui dit bon de rien madame j'ai fait ce
que je pouvais faire
merci on rentre on demande mondiale adam
merci madame est ce qu'on peut avoir le
numéro pour vous dis merci parce qu'il
ya vous avez sauvé une dame end on ne
recommence pas 0 0 336 elle vit en
france et l appel est lancé pour les
aider quelqu'un
on dit qu'au lycée tout c'est ça c'est
la communauté et on s'arrête pas là nous
on a c'est qu'on a sacrifié notre 25
notre 31 décembre on a les grandes
remises le 24 décembre et le 31 décembre
c'est ce que je voulais dire où tout le
monde en train de fêter et où nous nous
sommes dit non on ne fait pas on serait
dans une salle en recueille les
informations d'autres sécurité des
autres que nous allons transmettre à la
police
et c'est ce que nous faisons chaque 24
décembre
chaque contenu et bénévolement avec nos
crédits data avec nos smartphones et le
parti vert
le pape est maire
dock valley police et cours je voudrais
vraiment remercier tous ceux qui sont
venus mais je voudrais que vous retenez
une seule chose c'est de se poser la
question soit même qu'est ce que
j'apporte dans ma communauté
il ne faut pas être là comme on le dit
combien mal et l'a dit mon ami me l'a
répété tout à l'heure il faut pas vivre
pour que sa présence soirée marquée mais
il faut vite pour que l'absence à ses
récentes
donc c'est ça un peu voilà un peu
l'histoire de policiers coup que tu veux
le rencontrer
merci à tous à l'année prochaine
[Applaudissements]